[Music]
all right
uh we got a lot to talk about hey what's
up guys mkbhd here and you may have
recently seen some version of the news
that huawei was cut off from google and
now all their android devices are in
limbo but clearly there's a lot more to
it this is a super complex topic with
policy and timelines and a whole bunch
of moving parts so i clearly didn't rush
this video out i wanted to actually take
my time to summarize this topic but here
we are so this
is everything you need to know so far
in one place so huawei in case you
didn't already know
based in china huge company absolutely
massive and they have all kinds of
businesses in tech they sell networking
equipment they sell computers
and they sell most notably smartphones
they are the number two largest by
market share smartphone vendor on planet
earth second only to samsung and right
above apple so as you may have heard or
read in the news over the past few
months the us and china have been
escalating this trade war from both
sides
plus there's been a history of security
concerns over the potential of u.s
companies buying huawei networking
equipment and then possibly getting
spied on by the chinese government u.s
government agencies were even banned
from buying huawei phones at all so no
matter how you view those things either
way huawei's status in the us has been
pretty shaky for a little while now for
various reasons they knew it we knew it
that's just the climate we're in so the
big new news now
is that the us government signed an
executive order into effect that added
huawei to effectively a black list of
companies that are restricted from doing
any business with any u.s company
at all
period it's been awarded a bunch of
different ways but that's basically what
went down and now the implications from
that have run
far and wide i mean nothing's really
rocked the tech world quite like this in
a little while so the biggest most
obvious headline from this is google
they're a u.s company huawei does
business with google they make android
phones so when this executive order came
out in response google complied by
stopping all business with huawei and
pulling their license to use android
that wasn't like a choice they made or a
decision they had really they're just
complying with the executive order
google's in the us huawei is not allowed
to do business with any company in the
u.s so they can't be sold any software
or any licenses so they can't use
android so this is of course terrible
news for huawei who by the way was
the fastest growing smartphone
manufacturer in the world they were
coming up quick on that number one spot
so now the big question we're all
wondering is
what does this mean for the past the
present and future huawei devices so for
huawei devices past and present like if
you own a huawei phone like me like a
p30 pro or you're thinking about getting
a p30 pro or a p30 here's the deal first
of all they were issued a 90-day
exemption so they will be able to
continue sending software updates and
security updates to existing huawei
phones for the next 90 days into august
so that sort of softens the blow a
little bit i guess and i do believe this
also includes honor by the way honor
being a brand that's owned completely by
huawei a sub brand of them but honor and
huawei phones are all sort of under the
same umbrella so these phones will all
still work and they'll still keep
getting software updates and also google
tweeted from their android account that
while they comply with us government
requirements services like google play
and security from google play protect
they will keep functioning on your
existing huawei device for now but
these phones
if things stay the way they are
basically these phones will most
certainly stop getting software updates
like even if you're not in the us no
matter where you are if your huawei
phone runs google services those will
stop and you'll stop these phones will
not get the latest version of android
basically at the end of this 90 day
extension whatever software version
these phones have is the one that
they'll have for the rest of their life
which is definitely not ideal so
what does huawei do from here like what
can huawei do about their future phones
and can huawei even make
future phones without any us business
help fun fact they spent 70 billion
dollars buying components for hardware
last year 11 billion of that went to u.s
companies like qualcomm intel etc and
actually arsenica has posted an article
with a pretty good breakdown of all the
parts and components that huawei's been
buying to make their smartphones and a
lot of them come from us companies the
gorilla glass the flash storage some
radios etc all from us from looking at
this list it doesn't seem totally
unrealistic that i mean they don't want
to obviously but they seem like they
could totally switch all of their
suppliers from u.s companies
to others to get around this it's not
what they want to do it involves
spending a lot of money and doing a lot
of work but they're one of the few oems
that doesn't rely on qualcomm for their
silicon they make their own kieran 980
chip for the mate 20 pro and the p30 pro
so in theory with a lot of effort they
could keep making these physical phones
and also bloomberg has reported that
huawei has built up a three-month
stockpile of the parts they like to use
ahead of this ban which is actually
pretty impressive but even if they did
replace all of these hardware suppliers
with alternatives in the next 90 days
the software is still the big question
how do you make a phone without google
without the android license without the
google play store technically android
itself is open source just bare bone
stock android is just an open source
project which has led many to speculate
you don't need a license you don't need
to do business with google to just use
aosp so they could use bone stock
android but that's not ideal because
even that is further and further from
the version google uses every day and
that still doesn't include things like
google services
gmail
youtube
it's just not ideal the more i read into
it it turns out huawei's been sort of
quietly bracing themselves for something
like this for a while
similar to samsung they've recognized
their reliance on google and google
services as a bad thing so they've been
slowly building things behind the scenes
to be able to get ready to replace them
supposedly they've been working on a
backup os that supports android apps and
they've been working on building their
own app store the problem is
that is an immense challenge to try to
get people to use an alternate os and an
alternate app store especially if it
doesn't look exactly the same as the one
they're used to especially the app store
and if you can't do business with us
companies you can't expect to be able to
negotiate your way into getting the
netflix's and pandoras and facebooks and
instagrams on your alternate app store
and even if you can we've seen others
like amazon try you've seen the amazon
app store right
amazon's a multi-billion dollar company
and the sad version of an app store that
they have is nowhere near a replacement
of the ones that we're used to so it's a
super massive challenge to try to build
up your own app store out of nowhere so
this spells a lot of work for huawei
like it shows how big of an impact just
getting cut from your ties with google
can have on your business they've seen
this coming they've known that this is
possible but now that it's happened it's
awful so the way things stand now they
could in theory after the 90 days is up
continue to make phones entirely through
nine us companies
but those phones wouldn't have
android they wouldn't have the google
play services which are crucial and they
wouldn't have the google play store
it's tough and of course it's not just
google that they're cut off from like
that that's the big headlining one
because they make a lot of android
phones but there's plenty of other us
companies that they do business with
microsoft intel nvidia huawei has been
making laptops and pretty good ones mind
you competitively for a while now
but as far as i can tell they can't keep
making
windows laptops
without doing business with microsoft
and intel and nvidia and these companies
that's brutal too so as a person that
really likes tech
all of this news is terrible because
having one less company means less
competition which is less incentive for
these companies to work hard and make
great stuff i mean we've seen it
ourselves with how good their phones
have gotten lately and how good they've
made all the phones around them even if
you're not a fan of huawei or if you
don't like their stuff we have to admit
that having them around is good for
consumers it's good for us and also side
note if you think about it this is also
pretty bad just specifically for folding
phones like the galaxy fold kind of just
had its own pr nightmare all by itself
over there for a couple weeks which sort
of turned people's heads to the other
folding phone that would be coming to
market soon which was gonna be the
huawei mate x
but now
i mean what if it can't even run android
but hey huawei is like i said a huge
company like a really huge company so i
guess if anyone can recover from such a
massive setback to multiple parts of
their business
i guess it's them
i mean this is not ideal at all their
ideal case would be the government
renegotiates things and they reverse the
executive order and things go back to
normal but in the case that that doesn't
happen at least they have
billions of dollars to try something but
even if they do come back if you think
about it the bigger damage might really
just be
the way people think about huawei as a
company to potentially buy products from
you know their reputation isn't exactly
great especially in the us so now good
luck trying to convince someone to spend
a thousand dollars instead of an iphone
onto huawei phone that
doesn't even have the play store or run
android anymore that's a tough sell if
you look back a very similar situation
happened to zte in 2018 last year they
got cut off from all their us business
relationships and they were never the
same they didn't exactly come back
strong from that but huawei is this
goliath so i'm i'm thinking things will
go a bit differently this time or at
least i'm hoping things will go
differently for the sake of competition
but to be honest this whole situation is
far from over these things evolve they
change over time i wouldn't be shocked
if this whole thing was reversed in the
next couple months just because that's
sort of the way things have gone
recently but as of right now we're just
kind of in this unsatisfying limbo as we
speculate about huawei's future
but that's basically all there is to
know right now there you have it
so that's been it i'll leave all the
links for all my sources down below in
case you want to read up on this
yourself and of course feel free to
share this video for anyone who might be
headline reading or curious about the
situation huawei's found themselves in
right now and i'll catch you guys in the
next video
peace